Somehow,
somehow, but
I'm my older sister
Sometimes I'm a helpless stupid and small person Aren't I a
very dirty person?
But at times
like that, I always feel that other things, such as the way other people live in the world, are all beautiful and wonderful
.
As long as
I'm traveling, I'm sure there's a lot of painful things and sad things lying around wherever I go
[Music] That
's why I can't think of stopping
traveling  It's fun to do,
for example, even if you need to kill someone, you'll want to keep doing
it.
Besides,
you can always quit,
so let's continue
.
Maybe I myself don't really understand
Maybe I'm lost
And maybe I'm continuing my journey to understand more
Tatami
I'm going to sleep Tomorrow I have to run a lot again
Sumi  Hey,
good night function
[music]
me
skill The next country is still thundering Hermes It's
almost two days long That's what you want to see in your country
Goodgood
Wind mode It's like
[music]
Stops  I'll do it
Meow,
how are you today?
I might run away
with it, or I might sell it all away before long.
That's what I said,
Marukyu,
isn't it?  And you say you're headed there
Oh of course I lived there The
country I was born in is stupidly safe
Everyone's friendly like Arbo  I
just hit him a little and he looked at me with a blank look,
so I came out, so what are you going to do
after moving?
So
[music]
And you've probably heard about
that Mr. Ger, too
.
He's a famous serial killer who fought in a band of terrorist robbers.
Somehow, Matsumoto escaped from prison just before he was hanged. Tour 6-4
.
But I'm sure even Kisaka will kill a lot freely and I'll be placed in the middle of
nowhere I'd like you to teach me various
things
Please protect your own luggage
[music]
Poppn
pa
I guess
that's right.
I'm ready for the time being
Go?  No matter what reason you kill someone inside, it's not a crime Do you
understand?
But that's right. The
rice cakes are clean and there are many people. There
are few police officers and none of the shops have sturdy shutters.
They are kind to travelers.
Ah, I see.
Rough people marching in groups, fighting over women at a bar, and
dogs walking around with the help of humans.
I didn't do it, but
[music]
Good night yesterday
Oh, oh, oh, Hermes
me
[music]
9 minutes
me
[music]
goo
Germany is a bonus
I have to serve
the traveler Thank you.
Kahaa I've never been robbed This is
to kill people
5 I don't
know what to do, but I don't know, so I always leave it
[Music]
This country's recommendation
Ah, yeah, how about it? It's delicious Oh, you're a traveler Oh, you're a traveler
.
The usual, of
course, the usual, please.
Just got a show car So tomorrow morning's jokes Today in Nayuki,
we can afford to eat that
Eh
[music
] How long will Mr. K be able to stay in this country
?
]
I hear that you are traveling around the world, but I don't know how far
you will go.I wonder if Mr. Motrad knows about it.
I think I'm suitable, but what kind of
person is someone who can bring people down
?
What is the law of his
heart?  I'll sell it
to help with my living
expenses.  Yes,
I don't care about this kind of thing.
I wonder if it's
Hermes I'm sorry, but after you understand it for a while, plug the
hole properly What are you saying, it's a rule?
9 Monja nezo
[music
] n
re
data
ah
ale ran
goodoo fugu
[music] n2 [music]
what did you say
ah ha ha ha
[music]
r you don't have 2 minutes to type like that  If you miss it, you'll explode I'm going to die
Open it then
ah ah ah ah
me
eh eh
What is it
[music]
Answer the question a Here on this stake It's
not allowed to kill people Because
this is a country where murder isn't mentioned in the liar ta it blooms the
I saw that head
what from
me  We are here under the name of
suma or saya.
What is
it? Vivi is biting and smart.
Not being prohibited does not mean being allowed
.  I'm not that kind of person I'm
just a citizen
[music]
I'm sorry I'm an old man named
Ger You're in danger
I'm chasing a
horse Oh, it
looks like someone is
here I'm going to stop I
'll do it I'll say yes How are you today
?  I want to ask,
what is it?
Well, I've been forced to do anything to save my own life I guess they just wanted to live a normal life
I don't want to kill anyone I
want to live in a safe country
If that's the case, then I'm sure you'll like that country
Okay,
thank you
So we're on this day
I just want to ask you one more thing No, it's just
too weird
I'll see for myself
I was
thinking of asking you before the difficult question at the station, but why
is it three days in one country?
[music]
ge
ani
farewell
sequel 5
aname But I keep on enduring ah ah ah ah
me
goodgood
say as much as you can
true
me
Teruyo Motorrad is happiest
when it's running When you go on a trip, you run every day, so every time is
really fun Why don't you suddenly know
?  I thought about it, but then I wondered why I was traveling yesterday, well,
I know there's
nowhere to go back to, but I've been hurt many times along the way, and I've been nearly killed Yesterday, I tried to settle down in one place.  I don't think
it's as good as yesterday I'll hire you anywhere if you're
a skilled person There was also a way to live with a priest
Yes, I think Hermes is right about that part But
even so, the function continues the journey  The reason
[music]
Somehow
Colosseum